It's now time
for tonight's #HashtagWars.
(cheering)
Well...
it is after midnight,
which means it is now officially
and technically Star Wars Day!
-(cheering, applause)
-And let me...
let me be
the first person on television
to say,
"May the Fourth be with you!"
Now, last year on Star Wars Day,
I met the famous
Mos Eisley cantina band,
Figrin D'an and the Modal Nodes.
-(whooping) -Uh, I used
to be their lead singer
until I went solo. Hey-yo.
Uh... we're gonna come up
with some jams
from a long time ago
in a galaxy far, far away
with tonight's hashtag
#StarWarsSongs.
Examples might be:
"Wind Beneath My X-Wing,"
and "Get Out of My Dreams,
Get Into My Carbonite."
I'm gonna put 60 seconds
on the clock, and begin.
-Randy.
-"Yoda One That I Want."
-Points!
-(laughter, applause)
Oh, that's... fantastic.
Points. Josh.
-"Hoth-line Bling."
-Yes, points. Kyle.
"Like a Virgin."
HARDWICK:
Oh, goddamn it.
No points.
-(laughter)
-I take that personally!
I've touched a lady.
Uh... Randy.
Uh, "Trap Queen Amidala"
-by Boba Fetty Wap.
-Points! Very good!
Kyle Kinane.
"Have You Ever
Really Loved a Woman?"
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Goddamn it.
(bleep)
Son of a bitch.
I'll give you points,
but I don't like it. Randy.
"Obi-Wan Is
the Loneliest Number."
-(laughter)
-Points.
-Josh.
-"Nothing Compares R2-D2 You."
-Yes, points!
-(cheering)
Kyle.
"Dancing With Myself."
-HARDWICK: Goddamn it! Points.
-(laughter)
-Josh.
-"Mo Money Mo Tauntauns."
-Points!
-(laughter)
Randy.
"R2-D2 Princes"
by Kylo Ren Doctor.
-Nice! Very well done! Points.
-(laughter)
Kyle Kinane.
"All the Single Ladies."
HARDWICK:
Goddamn it!
Your words are like knives,
Kyle Kinane.